so I guess I'm curling my eyebrows today
which I've never done before I feel very
excited because I've never curled my
eyelashes before I don't really get to
do anything with the eyelashes as a guy
of it and have them we are gonna make me
look fabulous
I'm afraid of poking myself in the eye I
feel like I won't completely fail it
I've seen these before and this really
frightens me it looked like like
medieval torture devices there are I
phones but yet this did not keep current
with technological upkeep why does this
look sexual I have no clue how to do
this but I'm going to just kind of
figure it out
raise this I know that's how do you
always like this I feel a slight tug I'm
really holding on to this thing I want
him to be the craziest eyelashes in the
office oh my gosh shift of your eye open
who invented this who was like my
eyelashes just need to go whoop do you
hold it for a while is that what happens
oh my god you could like up your eyelid
with this it's like all my worst fears
uh-huh nothing's happening
oh I'm fleek oh yeah their little curls
I don't think I really made a difference
mute L it makes you look like foxy ER
all right here goes the other one you
like curl the bottom too
no I want to out curl for my
girlfriend's eyelashes like yeah what's
up now kind of relaxing does this
actually do anything I don't think I
look terribly different but it's you
know it's something that those lashes
[ __ ] yeah get it I get it yeah that
feels great
they're pretty yeah you know this little
device works
who knew it's so weird I don't think
this is effective you being lied to
women no man has ever noticed if you
just perfectly or not I was nervous
about this I thought this would actually
be harder it's quite easy actually I
don't hate it you know although I did
feel like my eyelashes were gonna get
chopped off look at that man this
marriage really magnifies everything
think I went to too deep into the
eyeball on that one it's like